hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome at our webinar we don't have
a lot of time ago whoa good God my own
shadow scared someone else's shadow to
scare me
okay odds about say not exactly very fun
they probably designed that specifically
like that did I knock it did I not get
that last time because I had no idea
what happened Oh was that the thing that
happened last time that I didn't notice
I honestly have no idea okay so if I
recall did not even notice you there
buddy sorry I really did not even notice
you there buddy but anyway I'm here to
turn off the gas so that and get through
that one area I'm assuming that I do
that here hello with some in mind
shutting out the gas that big guy from
the first game stop farting in there so
we can all pass through all kids walk on
through it yes like oh wait a minute no
this ain't right like creepy crawl on
the ground hold my breath what was that
okay god I keep hearing these weird
noises all over the place and I know
that everything is absolutely
intelligently designed in this game just
like that is that the buzz saw that the
buzz saw of a cannibal man trying to eat
my everything oh god there are body
parts in there
I know tell accountable man because
that's gonna be a feast for him anybody
here what about it home knock knock why
the heads in the jar eyes are long in
the jar too there's a lot of questions
but I don't think they're gonna be
answered over here okay for once in my
life I would love for things to be
perfectly normal in these areas but
somehow I don't think that's actually
gonna happen
I hear you look oh god damnit you were
right there
I hear you you're right in front of my
face and I still don't know where to go
look please all alone that's a dead end
isn't it
close it very gently oh good for me give
me while I pick up this battery and
defend myself walk into this gas you
know uh come in here it smells real bad
hello go over the bed oh god I'm so dead
don't yell they wrote run okay I
shouldn't know something bad was gonna
happen when I heard the buzz saw and
also I think I'm supposed to be taking
advantage of these hiding places that
just happened to be oh I don't know
everywhere huh yeah me other way
here's the damn thing there's another
dead end
we got a ball round bye-bye ha this
you're giving that again Oh get out of
here you stupid [ __ ] oh if I'd have
just gone down the hallway I would have
been fine okay I'm not fine because they
keep going in to stop it
hi okay bye thank you thank you for that
here's where I'm supposed to go I think
[ __ ] hell you weren't there before
son of a [ __ ] why oh my goodness gravy
okay so there's gas everywhere but I
guess it's not really a problem
got it loops in a circle am I supposed
to do oh boy do I go what do I do
that's [ __ ] out there's a sink gasp
music okay gas room this way who the
hell is it
where where where up up up up of course
off of course off but I'm dead you suck
ass
what how long
you guys didn't see cuz I cut a little
bit out of that but I was looking around
for a long time forgot that I needed to
look up oh I diamond it I'm stupid I am
terribly dumb and I should not be
allowed to play video games and the vo
the general public
so is he over here this time look why is
him that may be not gonna be over here
no no how I just peeked my head a little
bit it up up up up up finally good god
dammit you son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna pretend like I got that in
like two minutes two minutes is a little
excessive but definitely not the six or
seven minutes that I was actually lost
running in circles over and over and
over and all day I got in a demon yeah I
don't know if I should be proud about
gas leaking possibility no no thank you
then that security door please lock wait
so what was appointed oh I need to go
back cuz I needed to open a gas room or
I needed open up mine's gonna happen
that's more gas not that much gas she
asked to enough to get by so you still
here bruh you sit here you're still here
I hear uh somehow he didn't spot me
don't mind me bro I just gotta go on my
way
no no no no run run run run run run run
run run go in here and out and close
we're good we're real good
we're so good so glad we're good
I'm so happy that good things are
happening me now okay so now that that
crisis of epic proportions is over I
don't even think of do I need to go that
way
oh yeah cuz that's where that guy died
you do not Oh what the hell what has
happened whoa whoa okay that was weird
is everything okay something jumped I
have no idea what though well I got my
character model is just walking ever so
lazily about like nothing is going wrong
in this world but I can't see anything
Oh God it was like dark just a second
ago maybe those is a fog I cannot see a
damn thing
wait hey I need this who's okay that
doesn't help at all I'm totally in the
fog is this supposed to be day out why
is it perpetual night in this place all
time okay there's some I like this a lot
I like this dark woods scary atmosphere
bring it on you [ __ ] losers laugh full
of it did I just rip did I trip and fall
did I slip trip and fall okay don't do
that to me oh that guy had a fun time
looks like a cool party happened over
here why am i up here all over here okay
don't trip again man don't slip slipping
is bad
her dad
no telepathy but you're actually think I
better run away from you a little weak
what you still there
zoomy still there and move on my way
thank you okay
it's quiet they required no no pussy's
not bring on okay I better run running
would probably an ideal thing to do
look gently they didn't see me of course
all there's nothing in this one that I
need I just killed myself maybe no whoa
what's going on over here why does this
go over here do I need to go up in this
room there's no way to go up so a lot
about all this there's one nice insane
asylum
well I like the atmosphere and what
you've done with the place gonna go in
there
whoa hi we're doin what oh good job doll
my favorite sports team guy do you shoot
those hoops
oh maybe uh there's something ha Jesus
balls an ass guy wasn't even trying to
get me they do think that I'm one of
them at least some of them do so that
guy that really likes to nibble on you
doing okay there buddy okay extend it on
people's brains tweeted I go to freakin
maze around here okay so obviously not
that way but I feel like this got
circles back to the area I was just in
maybe not where the hell am I
eyes are so quiet here
least I get a mobile to relax I think oh
hi didn't notice you at first you are
alright buddy
wasn't sure what happened there okay oh
boy do I get to go in the sewers
I like the sewers I like the sewers a
lot oh okay oh no wait I'm going up oh I
thought that was gonna be another sewer
level like before in the last 100 can't
be all sunshine and rainbows sometimes
we gotta get dragged through the muck
look at the prison courtyard shoot
b-ball outside of the school these guys
up to no good better not make trouble in
my neighborhood hi folks this is dudes
it's a naked twins hi buddy oh god they
put more detail into you that is a weird
crop top that you got going on there
let me just dock you'd meant that for
posterity speaking of posterity bye
alright ya cry mentioned that those guys
were some of the most interesting
characters in the first game and they
were like very underutilized so I'm kind
of hoping /not hoping that they're more
featured in the next area that I'm going
into and I'm kind of realizing what's
about to happen to me so that's good
that's good hi how you doing still naked
good I'll just tell
young come at me don't let me god it's
so weird
whoa goodness gracious nothing is
actually happening oh I see what you
were playing with oh you want to play
with me gonna play with me you want to
play with me
Marc Marc oh okay I'm sorry you got
Justin skins or [ __ ] off all right
tell me do you like uppercutted me and
I'm half dead oh thank you it's so
disconcerting look sexually after night
episode is weird whole episode is weird
what does this look like a
maximum-security prison turned into an
arcane asylum arcana's I'm insane okay
hello
what does it read Kurt we've got another
one and I'm not sure you're gonna be
able to check it off a psychopathic
psychopathic proximity disorder security
guard all the way up in the admin block
is our latest non patient employee to
see you start seeing Wernicke's fairy
tales
he was never directly exposed to the
engine never even made it below level
one in the building it would be an
enormous breach of protocol and security
if doctors were speaking of the walrider
within hearing of a contracted security
guard and seems vanishingly improbable
that he would stumble upon such an
obscure mythological story on his own
it's too similar to the dr. Samuel Cray
saml case or the others before him it's
one thing for formerly same medical
personnel to fall under delusions of
their patients it's another thing
entirely for those beliefs to be I don't
know airborne we need to talk in person
Billings is why did someone just print
out an email for me to read in there a
Bennett computer okay so anyway these
these periods of relaxation that they're
building up so there's more piers
attention are
laughs like a gal okay forget the period
to come there's no common air whoo-hoo
what am i doing
what am i doing what's going on what
happened who am i coming back to am I
supposed to oh hello you okay
you don't look so good I'm not saying he
looks bad but you just had better days
something needed to come back come on
Gabe but I've got rock steel hard that
didn't sound right
I've got resolved oh hi buddy I've got
resolved to see it through to the end or
whatever nothing there that's locked go
up here say hi to the guy up here I got
to keep my eyes open because there's so
many hidden details that I'm not
observing it's hard to watch him talking
freak out so do its science but it's not
okay
they were waiting for us cruel in this
place yeah Billy understood cool they've
always been here right good for you
okay battery but what else do I need why
am I here okay I thought that might have
a
is that going on in there what's going
on in there
what are you doing in there stop that
right now
stop that crap you leave him alone or
I'll come in there and do something
about it but come in there and do
something about I'm out a walk bye-bye
I didn't sound good that sounds big and
shakey very worrisome like some big guys
about to go some big guys about to come
barreling through there uh I'm just
gonna walk calmly okay all right we're
good we're good we're so good we're
better than good keep thinking things
are about to happen when I think they're
gonna happen they don't which I guess is
a good sign of this games oh god damn it
please tell me that was a button that I
didn't manage suppressing here button
button button button button mind about
him oh here we go god damn it was right
in front of me sorry everybody reading
reading reading bad things hi okay it's
you again
really
why such an [ __ ]
oh my nose wailing yeah you couldn't
guess couldn't just keep perhaps now
could just play along okay
No
give me a favorite nine-year no you were
supposed to get it you just want to get
killed I was not supposed to get killed
who's after me they're a big guy big guy
what happened
Oh No
let's big guy Chris Walker I remember
your name all the sudden don't you
please don't throw me toast at my deck
no oh that was my head ripped off good
to see you too Chris
are you Ben has a family you've been
working out I miss you big buddy oh god
damn it
okay so Chris is coming I better move
okay okay yeah go through there hi Chris
how you doing buddy good friend oh good
friend behind this corner he won't see
me right
hey Chris
hi Chris yeah go in that room yeah I'm
in there yeah yeah oh you're looking
good oh no no that's right that's right
that's right that's right
that's right that's right that's right
NASA that's it that's right you better
run away better run away better run away
else hello can I hide with you I swear
I'm not a psycho guy friend friend
friend friend friend that's cool thank
you laughs god damn it you're agile no
let me go
that's resting my body on the ground
there so he's gonna go around that
corner so he's gonna go around that
corner I'm asleep right through here no
no no no open it run very quickly for us
that way I don't care I don't care I
don't care whatever whatever whatever
run run run run run run run run run
that's right right don't push adlai why
won't you bend it open run quickly Oh
little bit you don't know they'll be
your home movie you do do you okay all
right good good thank you okay
so we're supposed to wait patiently
until help arrives and why wasn't this
evacuation happening before okay so I'm
gonna stand in its loving room and end
this episode here okay god this game it
never gives you a break
why mean it does give you a break but I
don't think it's a break what is
happening so anyway thank you all so
much for watching let me know what you
think in the comments below you do what
you want I hope you're enjoying the
series as much as I am so thank you all
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
I did it
pretty pretty princess did you go
Hey